salut aujourd'hui on est dans les loges
du grand point virgule et on vient de
finir les hallucinations collectives et
autres illusions fantastique là il se
passe un truc de fou ya giorgio qui va
essayer de mentaliser farid du grand
show time ball farida a beaucoup
d'argent
enfin beaucoup d'annoncés donc je vais
regarder de petites pièces on va voir si
tu vas manger dresse un format que je
donne ma poche arrière
ouais je sais rien droite très important
du pantalon vert bouteille alors ce
qu'on va faire c'est que confus on
regarde tu vas fermer les mains est ce
que je vais faire c'est que je vais
essayer de changer la pièce de 1 euro
avec la peine de 50 centimes ce qui va
se passer c'est que j'ai besoin d'auto
hypnose est d'accord mais en fait tu vas
pas te rends compte que tu vas avoir ce
qu'on appelle un micro sommeil
ce qui va nous permettre d'ouvrir les
mains de changer de tête est tombée
tellement pertes actuelles marianne la
étude montre avec julie on sait comment
ça marche les gens n'y aura pas
d'audience à toute façon ma main vers
les yeux a plutôt bien fort bien forfait
un résultat du mois elle doit elle t'a
vu ça va vite on regarde aller
publiquement voilà tu vois c'est ouf
et là maintenant après on peut ainsi
voir des trucs ça alors c'est vrai oui
attention on y voit ce que je vais faire
c'est que je vais passer d'une main à
l'autre tu vas regarde d'où tu n'es rien
tu te tue sont pas là ben oui c'est
comment ça va se passer dans l'autre
je sers bien les pièces c'est bon ça y
est sûr oui ça y est c'est parti
sulawesi ah merde c'est raté c'est quoi
je lui offrant un cadeau je vais
t'offrir un cadeau un euro tiens pop
c'est vraiment peut-être c'est à black
or vraiment que tu me disais ouais ça me
fait très plaisir des jolis jeux se
porta que ça me fait très plaisir je
vais bruxelles et à ma taille donc
c'était ce qui est très bien vu la
couleur taupe une découpe leur manquait
très bien c'est difficile de choisir un
cadeau pour déclencher
bravo giorgio merci beaucoup je rejoue
dès jeudi et vendredi et samedi au-delà
du trévise avec mon mental experts un
emmental experts 2 way et bientôt
mentale experts 3 sas a fait la troupe
du grand chelem que vous pouvez au plus
haut point virgule les vendredis et
samedis et une fois par mois au grand
point virgule pour une exceptionnelle en
fait et il ya toujours un geste
j'en ai d'ailleurs pourquoi tant mentale
john ciao